[Music]
video heart like a truck
[Music]
it's gonna be so fun that was an
exclusive look behind the scenes from
lainey wilson's new music video for her
brand new single heart like a truck
joining us now is the country singer
herself hey girl it is so good to see
you it is so good to see you
we have to talk about that cmt music
awards performance
in the pouring rain pouring rain
hair was drenched my poor hair and
makeup artist was upset she had been
working on me all day and then just
torrential downpour
but
honestly one of my favorite moments of
my career so far with my buddy
coleslandell like
it was pretty magical it was picture
perfect too yeah with the raindrops
coming down like what was actually going
through your mind at the time were you
at all worried that there's rain there's
electricity yes
i was like well let's just hope we don't
get electrocuted but about like three
minutes before
the show started
it just the sky opened up and nashville
and just decided you know to do its
thing and i looked at cole when we got
on stage and i said we're gonna do this
thing and he was like let's do it so we
just walked out on the thrust and uh we
gave it our best shot and it was it was
pretty dang cool a few people like were
commenting online and they were like i
love this song i love laney and cole
singing together but i just don't
understand the rain and i'm like well
it's because
we can't do anything about it it's
mother nature y'all yes i mean what an
incredible year for you yes
when you wrote things a man i don't know
do you have any inkling that it would
bring you to where you are now that it
would be that little song that could
yeah i know a few things a man ought to
know man
it's so crazy like two weeks before we
went in to record my record things a man
i don't know was not even on the list
it was not on the list to even record
and i remember exactly where i was in
nashville when
i had this overwhelming feeling that we
were supposed to record it so you know i
had to call the label and be like i know
we've already got our our songs picked
out but for some crazy reason my gut and
my heart is telling me that we've got to
cut the song and
it has changed it has changed my life
it's changed my team's life my family's
life and like you just said it was the
little song that never gave up now i
would ask you how do you top a song like
that but i feel like i know the answer
because your new single heart like a
truck i mean girl
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you that means a lot wow thank you
what is the back story behind this new
song oh my gosh you know it's just about
it's really um
seeming autobiographical and it's just
like talking about the things that that
i've been through that have gotten me to
where i am you know about where i've
been but also where i'm going um
there is something so cool about finding
freedom and strength
and
and being okay and embracing your scars
and the bumps along the way because at
the end of the day that's what builds
character it makes us who we are that's
it and so that's what it's about you
know it's about it's for anybody and
everybody who's ever had heartbreak hard
luck hard times
you name it we've all been there and
look at us on the other side of it
that's it that's it you mentioned where
you've been and where you're going yep
where are you going what where do you
see yourself in the next few years this
has been my dream and my my life's
mission is just to sing country music it
is my life um i'm from a town of 263
people where country music truly is
just it's our life i didn't even realize
it was a genre growing up but um
i just i just want to continue being
able to say what i want to say how i
want to say it and keep being me
unapologetically me and i want to
encourage everybody else to do that too
and
it's going to be pretty dang cool to see
where we are in a few years but
the crowds are going to get bigger the
music is going to get louder
let's go i'm pumped now this new single
also falls at a special time in your
life your 30th birthday was that planned
it was not planned it just happened and
what a birthday present yeah
i'm just i'm excited for my 30s yeah uh
my 20s were interesting a lot of great
things happened i mean i signed my first
publishing deal i got a record deal my
first song went to country radio
but
the first
seven years of my 20s
were rough i mean i was i was living in
my camper trailer i was just
trying to figure it out just like we all
are in this life and
and at the end of the day that's what
it's about but i have a feeling my 30s
are going to look a lot different what
is the vibe you're going into the
mindset that you're going into your 30s
with oh my gosh really and truly just
like really embracing who i am
um
along the way there's a lot of people's
opinions
and i'm just going to keep my blinders
on
and stay in my own lane and do what i do
and that's all i can do but um but yeah
30s are 30s are looking good i mean
after your 20s
i mean
you have is there anything
that you have a specific goal for your
30s knowing what you've accomplished
already in your 20s is there anything
that is in the back your mind for your
30s
oh my goodness there's so many things i
don't want to do like if if you would
have looked at like my list of things
that i wanted to do like i had set a
goal list
for this year and we truly have like we
have crossed off a lot of those things
um
and it's it's just it's pretty crazy
how far you can come if you just really
like
dive into it head first and just do the
dang thing
but uh but yeah there's there's so much
i want to do i want to continue doing
collaborations with people i think that
is the coolest thing that country music
has really gotten into lately
um i think it's cool to be able to like
share each other's crowds
and that's that's been a huge deal for
me especially with this cole swindell
song i mean
he has really embraced me
and kind of showed the rest of the world
like hey i believe in this girl and
maybe you should too
and it's important to have people like
that along the way so
i just want to continue putting out
music
that is who i am to my core all of the
things that you learned in your 20s
going into this music it is crazy how
you carry it on over
so that's it you mentioned the
collaborations is there anybody in
particular that you may have
conversations with already right now or
that you're eyeing that you really
wanted there's so many collaborations i
want to do of course like in the country
world i'd love to do
eric church dolly parton you name it
like
chris stapleton brothers osborne
so many i also love bruno mars i think
he is so cool i love alan stone i'm i
mean i'm shooting big but we have to
that's it we're all about manifesting
too have you pursued the jolly collab
because i feel like i mean you too we
haven't he's a god i think we would get
along just i think you guys have not met
yet stop it we have not met
but i think we would be best buds i
think she's best buds with anybody
probably so maybe that first meeting
then you talk about the collab i'm
telling you she dolly parton
hands down one of the biggest
inspirations
i mean for so many people around the
world but just who she is
the way that she tells it how it is a
little bow wrapped on top
she's just she's just a good person got
a heart of gold i think we were if we
were all a little bit more like her the
world would be a much better place well
you are because you are authentically
you and that's something that jolly is
and that has gotten her to where she is
that's one thing that i've tried to to
take from her w
double d
what would jolly do wwt what would jolly
jump i had to put them double d's in it
you